let's talk about what's going on the
David Pakman show subreddit we do have a
discussion forum it doesn't live on our
own website but it's over on reddit at
WWE pakman.com slash a reddit that is re
d di t nearly 7,000 of our viewers and
listeners regularly participating in non
trolling respectful friendly mostly
political discussion and debate a few
interesting threads I noticed this
morning when checking out the david
pakman show subreddit is the 3d
blueprints for guns a First Amendment or
Second Amendment issue this is an
interesting question the viewer says
from what I understand I read about some
case where some programmer wrote a book
about making strong security algorithms
and the court sided with him in
releasing the book to bypass the US
export laws regarding weapons expert he
is only releasing the blueprints for the
guns and there is already federal law
that prohibits the use of fully black
plastic guns what are your thoughts yeah
this is interesting because on the one
hand you have the legality of the gun
itself and separate from that is
effectively speech right or text that
would tell you or have instructions for
how to print that gun so are 3d printed
guns a First Amendment or Second
Amendment issue from what I've read it's
not really a First Amendment issue right
now and I've referenced this case about
a bomb-making guide from the 60s or 70s
I think that it is actually more of a
Second Amendment issue but there's a lot
going on related to this we talked about
it on a bonus show Bendixon talked about
it on yesterday's program filling in for
me we will see whether the 3d printed
guns evolves to be more of a first or
second amendment issue also from the
david pakman show subreddit don't worry
too much about the 3d printed guns to be
non-detectable you would have to have
plastic ammunition also and the thing
would likely blow up in your face you
know this is sort of a false dichotomy
because you don't only have plastic or
metal ammunition and part of the issue
is that there are 3d printers that use
other composite materials which may
not trigger a metal detector but might
be more effective than straight up
plastic ammunition so that may be
something that makes it less of a
concern today but even a year out that
could be very different and I don't
think it's really material to the debate
around the legality also from the David
Pakman show subreddit should
totalitarianism be used to describe
Trump in my opinion this blurs the
discussion totalitarianism is something
different than plain authoritarianism at
least in my opinion it is about an
ideology that wants to take subject an
entire state and society to its
apocalyptic and violent ideology you
should be very careful with analogies
with totalitarianism
I completely agree I believe that we
want to be accurate when we talk about
political ideology and this is why if
we're talking about socialism great but
if we're talking about social democracy
then we should use the term social
democracy unless we actually agree that
the definitions of these terms have
changed along the same lines
Donald Trump has authoritarian
tendencies he seems to be quite taken by
authoritarian dictators in other
countries but the United States is not
currently totalitarian would it become
that if Donald Trump was allowed to push
his authoritarianism to its full
conclusion whatever it is he has in mind
yeah maybe but I agree that
totalitarianism right now is simply not
the right term for what was happening in
the United States lastly from the david
pakman show subreddit is David Sacha
Baron Cohen I don't even know what this
means I don't know where this came from
we did a few stories related to Sacha
Baron Cohen's new Showtime program who
is America I don't think I look like the
guy I'm certainly not British and I
don't know exactly what people mean but
we are both Jewish I don't know if
that's what people are pointing at
somebody can explain that one to me I'd
love to hear hear and learn more about
it join the discussion at david
pakman.com slash re d di t